ya tenemos bastante experiencia
calculando áreas bajo la curva cuando
tenemos coordenadas rectangulares
tomamos la suma de riman para una gran
cantidad de rectángulos que tiene
infinito a medida que se hacen
infinitamente pequeños y de esa manera
obteníamos el área pero ahora veamos qué
sucede cuando tenemos coordenadas
polares en coordenadas polares no
encontramos propiamente el área bajo la
curva aquí por ejemplo tenemos la
gráfica de r igual a efe dt está trazada
desde que teta es igual a alfa hasta que
teta es igual a beta lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es obtener una expresión
general para encontrar el área de esta
región que estoy marcando en azul esta
región que podemos decir que está
acotada por esos ángulos y la gráfica de
r igual a efe de teta r igual a efe de
teta y me gustaría que intentes
desarrollar la expresión por ti mismo
para lo cual te voy a dar una ayuda
cuando hicimos el cálculo en coordenadas
cartesianas dividimos las regiones
rectángulos aquí los rectángulos no son
tan obvios pues todos parecerían llegar
a este punto
pero qué tal si dividimos la región en
estos que podríamos denominar sectores o
más bien rebanadas de página así es que
ahora en vez de tomar las áreas de
rectángulos como hicimos en coordenadas
cartesianas vamos a tomar el área de
cada una de estas secciones que tenemos
aquí que efectivamente parecen rebanadas
de pan
posteriormente tomaremos el límite a
medida que estas rebanadas se hacen cada
vez más pequeñas y por consiguiente el
número de rebanadas se hace cada vez más
grande
es decir tomaremos el límite cuando el
número de rebanadas tiende a infinito y
aquí te voy a dar otra ayuda esta ayuda
te va a servir para calcular el área de
estas que ya estamos viendo que
efectivamente parecen rebanadas de pan
veamos voy a dibujar aquí lo mejor
posible un círculo
voy a hacer mi mejor esfuerzo para que
quede efectivamente como un círculo aquí
estaría el centro así es que si tengo un
círculo no quedo tan mal verdad un
círculo cuyo radio acr cuyo radio es r y
si aquí tenemos un sector del círculo
este es un sector del círculo aquí
también tenemos r y si este ángulo mide
teta entonces cuál va a ser el área de
este sector cuál va a ser el área de
este sector es la ayuda que te puedo dar
suponiendo que el ángulo theta estén
radiales como calculas el área de este
sector y ver si puedes extender eso a lo
que estamos intentando hacer aquí de
alguna manera y aquí va otra ayuda usar
integración para poder calcular el área
de toda esta región supongo que ya lo
intentaste pensemos entonces primero en
esto para empezar cuál es el área del
círculo completo eso ya lo sabemos el
área de un círculo se calcula como pi
por radio al cuadrado fórmula para el
área del
así que el área del sector va a ser
entonces una fracción del área del
círculo si este ángulo es zeta y tomamos
en cuenta que una vuelta completa
corresponde a un ángulo de 2 y radiales
así es que el área del sector es una
fracción theta sobre 2 pi del área del
círculo multiplicamos entonces por theta
sobre eta sobre
te estás sobre 2 p y obtenemos el área
del sector la cual calculamos como el
área del círculo por la fracción que
corresponde al sector con respecto a
todo el círculo aquí podemos simplificar
para obtener que el área del sector es
igual a un medio de rr cuadrada por
theta ahora qué sucede si en lugar de
theta consideramos cada uno de estos
pequeños ángulos cada uno de estos
pequeños ángulos que dibujé aquí vamos
ahora enfocarnos entonces en una de
estas pequeñas rebanadas como esta de
aquí que estoy resaltando en naranja y
aquí la tenemos marcada en naranja en
vez de que el ángulo sea theta vamos a
suponer que el ángulo que define la
rebanada es realmente pequeño vamos a
tomar el diferencial del ángulo quizás
matemáticamente es mucho más complicado
pero lo que intento darte es la base
conceptual de esto tendríamos que tomar
delta theta y luego el límite cuando
delta theta tiende a cero pero estoy
dándole un enfoque más bien intuitivo
así es que suponemos que aquí tenemos un
cambio muy pequeño infinitamente pequeño
en theta llamémosle
de teta de teta mientras que el radio el
radio de esta rebanada o la longitud
podríamos decir de esta pequeña rebanada
va a ser r como función de teta esta
longitud está dada por r como función
del ángulo teta allí así es que esta
longitud está dada por r así es que cuál
va a ser entonces el área de este
pequeño sector el área de este pequeño
sector en donde en vez de llamar al
ángulo theta lo estoy llamando de teta
el diferencial de teta así es que el
área en vez de ser un medio de re
cuadrada theta va a ser vamos a ponerlo
aquí el área de este sector va a estar
dada por un medio de r cuadrada de theta
notamos que aquí el ángulo fue theta y
aquí fue de teta súper súper súper
pequeño ahora si quiero tomar la suma de
las áreas de todos esos pequeños
sectores desde que t t es igual a alfa
hasta que te des igual a beta recordando
que son sectores infinitamente pequeños
con lo cual el número de ellos es
infinito
grande lo que tenemos que hacer para
calcular el área de toda la región es
simplemente integrar esta expresión así
es que el área de toda esta región va a
estar dada por la integral desde que
teta es igual a alfa hasta que teta es
igual a beta del área de cada uno de
estos sectores es decir de un medio de
rr cuadrada de teta donde r por supuesto
es una función de teta así es que esto
lo podemos escribir como esto es igual a
la integral desde alza hasta beta de un
medio de r de teta elevado al cuadrado
de teta insistiendo que en este caso
estamos suponiendo que r es una función
de teta